have a million children well maybe not
actually a million
but hilaria and alec baldwin have
officially welcomed
baby number six yes on monday the proud
mom shared this photo alex snapped to
instagram
surrounded by her new baby and her five
other children
two-year-old romeo four-year-old
leonardo five-year-old rafael
seven-year-old carmen and five-month-old
eduardo whom the couple welcomed in
september
alec also shares 25 year old daughter
ireland with
ex-wife kim basinger if you have kids
and
if you're like us sometimes you feel
like you can't stop having kids
news of baby number six was kept a
secret and it's unclear if the baby
arrived via surrogate
or adoption last april hilaria announced
that the couple was expecting their
fifth child
just months after revealing hilaria had
previously suffered two miscarriages
the yoga instructor opened up to et
about why she chose to share the
experience
publicly personally i believe when you
go through something difficult the
sooner that you make it real the sooner
you can do with
do something with it the more that you
talk about it the more you make it real
i know this is something that i
did not want to go through and would
never ever want to go through again
has been that how many people come
forward and said that they have
more courage to share these kinds of
things it's much more common than you
think the baldwin's happy baby news
comes on the heels of a controversy that
erupted in december surrounding
hilaria's heritage
and calling her ethnicity background and
accent
into question at the time hilaria
addressed the allegations on instagram
there's been some questions about
where i'm born i'm born in boston and
then i spent
some of my childhood in boston some of
my childhood in spain
my family my brother my parents my
nephew everybody is over there in spain
now i'm here
and so there was like a lot of back and
forth my entire life
after a brief social media hiatus
hilaria returned to instagram in
february
and further clarified her background in
this instagram post
writing quote i've spent the last month
listening reflecting
and asking myself how i can learn and
grow
my parents raised my brother and me with
two cultures american and spanish
and i feel true sense of belonging to
both
you